Vsauce!
Kevin here.
It's Spring Cycle Learn Time.
Spring Fever is not listed under a real diagnostic
medical category but is often associated with
increased birth rates and the lifting of winter
depression.
However, its original connotation may have
literally been with actual sickness.
It's said American colonists coined the term
to describe weakness and fatigue after months
without fruits and vegetables - symptoms attributed
to scurvy.
An advanced symptom of the condition which
peaked during Spring - being fever.
The cycle of seasons from Winter to Spring
is marked by the vernal equinox - the day
when the Earth's axis is pointed parallel
to the sun making day and night close to equal.
But not exactly equal because the sun's ray
are bent by the Earth's atmosphere so we can
actually see the sun before it rises and after
it sets.
If we lived in a world without air - then
the equinox would truly be an equal night.
The singing of Winter birds like chickadees
and mockingbirds is one of the earliest signs
of Spring but baby birds need to learn how
to sing.
Like human infants they start out babbling
before learning to string together different
sounds correctly.
Baby birds raised by humans are often unable
to sing as adults, but can learn from hearing
recordings of adult birds of the same species.
The reason for Daylight Saving Time is to
make better use of daylight and it was first
suggested by Benjamin Franklin.
London builder William Willett spent a fortune
advocating for it because he noticed people
wouldn't wake up earlier to use the daylight
but could take advantage of it in the evening.
Despite being controversial with people like
farmers who wake at dawn - it was enacted
as law by governments to save energy during
World War I and again in World War II in which
a year round Daylight Saving Time in the US
was called "War Time".
Which equals - Spring Clean Time
Spring cleaning has deep roots around the
world including Middle Eastern tradition where
it's thought to bring vibrancy to the new
year, Jewish tradition where every single
crumb of unleavened bread must be removed
before Passover and in Chinese tradition as
a means of removing misfortune that may have
accumulated during the year.
Scientifically, in cold winter climates the
air is dry which leads to dry skin for you
and your pets which leads to flaking and therefore
more dust building up in your home that has
closed windows and doors.
So once its warm enough to open those up - it's
time for spring cleaning.
And as always - thanks for watching.